bonjour eric bocquet merci d'être avec
nous ce matin en direct sur arte france
alors on attendait des nouvelles mesures
plus strictes ce soir la france qui est
un des rares pays européens à écarter
l'option du confinement qu'en pensez
vous je pense qu'il faut pas l'écarter
complètement on a vu que cette mesure
avait été efficace au printemps dernier
évidemment ça les conséquences mais bon
là tout est mis en oeuvre pour soutenir
l'économie se tenir à au mieux les
populations même s'il ya beaucoup à
faire de ce domaine là et surtout éviter
que ça soit payée par la dette ensuite
c'est à nous tous il fine est donc long
je pense pas qu'il fallait exclure
absolument cette option parce qu'elle
est encore une fois elle avait fait la
preuve de son efficacité pour enrayer ou
engager un début d'engagement de
l'épidémie au printemps dernier sur la
table il y avait également peut-être la
fermeture des cantines scolaires ça a
été évoqué mais s'est mis de côté
aujourd'hui le conseil scientifique qui
considèrent comme inutile la fermeture
des écoles quel est votre avis on entend
les parents d'élèves inquiets on dit que
tous les lieux de rassemblement quel
qu'il soit même avec certaines
précautions sont des lieux où qui
favorise la propagation du virus donc
voilà on est dans l'entre-deux on est
pas au fonctionnement 100% de la société
on n'est pas dans le confinement on est
dans le pas à pas entre ces deux options
et voilà dès qu'il ya du monde c'est ce
qu'on nous dit en tout cas c'est ce que
les épidémiologistes nous explique le
risque les grandes une propagation plus
rapide de ce virus dont on parle
maintenant de deux versions variante
issus d'afrique du sud au royaume uni on
y voit pas très clair puisque jean
françois hébel frais si justement le
président du conseil scientifique a
également plaidé pour la reprise d'une
partie des cours en présentiel à
l'université à cause des dégâts
psychologiques causés notamment par la
crise sanitaire qu'en pensez vous
le problème c'est que on n'a pas d'eau
on n'a pas la junte sont très claires on
entendait des injonctions
contradictoires
beaucoup de gens s'expriment sans doute
compétents les uns les autres
il n'y a pas un pape pilotage national
finalement dans cette affaire et aux
gaufres et à mesure des interventions
des uns et des autres on arrive parfois
à des injonctions tout à fait
contradictoires
la population est en attente la
population est fatiguée
au plan économique le plan social au
plan psychologique
commença à se sentit à s'exprimer là on
ne sait plus vraiment où varès qui a
encore un pilote dans l'avion
sortie de crise en septembre prochain
doute également le conseil scientifique
à condition de vacciner la population
quel est votre avis sur la stratégie de
la vaccination du gouvernement
aujourd'hui mais honnêtement je suis
très inquiet très inquiet au fil des
réunions qu'on peut avoir en région mais
qui est préfet les ars hier nous avions
la question la science est question des
fuites ce gouvernement c'est notre
collègue laurence cohen qui a posé la
question au gouvernement on n'est
vraiment pas rassuré le gouvernement se
satisfait de ce démarrage poussif des
vaccinations dans notre pays on annonce
un million pour fin janvier mais ça veut
dire qu'il faudrait passer à 50 milles
vaccination jours à compter de cette
date
est ce qu'on à l'approvisionnement
nécessaire on a un problème de
transparence sur les informations il
faudrait vacciner
le préfet de région a annoncé la semaine
dernière à il faudra arriver à un
chiffre de 35 millions de vaccinés en
france pour l'été et disons ici six sept
mois
très bien mais il faut vraiment au
niveau logistique améliorer les choses
que quand on voit à notre contre
performance entre guillemets le nombre
de personnes vaccinées à la date
d'aujourd'hui comparativement y compris
à des voisins européens on a quelques
inquiétudes sur l'organisation générale
pourtant conseillé par un cabinet privé
kevin américain qui nous coûte de
l'argent et franchement la prestation
n'est pas à la hauteur on a des
interrogations sérieuses sur
l'organisation logistique de cette
campagne de vaccination doit vous
paraître ce cabinet privé olivier
verrons a été auditionné effectivement
avant-hier par par le sénat sur cette
question et on voit pas très bien quel
conseil ce cabinet privé aurait pu
donner à la france ben hur le la lenteur
de la vaccination aujourd'hui oui après
c'est un problème d'organisation savez
les gouvernements successifs depuis
quelques décennies ont dépassé leur
temps à déshabiller l'état déshabiller
les administrations désorganisé au monde
la réduction de la dépense publique
nécessaire suppression des postes et on
arrive aujourd'hui à un état et
malheureusement pas toujours en capacité
d'assumer les fonctions qui devraient
contrôler les siennes donc on paye aussi
des années d'austérité et de réduction
des moyens de la force publique devant
la commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale hier au lit
également justifier la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire ça doit être
sur la table
lundi ce sera discuté écouter ce qu'il a
dit justement aujourd'hui nous ne
pouvons nous priver d'aucun outil
susceptible de nous aider à combattre le
virus
si l'état d'urgence sanitaire tombe il
n'y a plus de couvre-feu par exemple
donc il n'y a plus de moyens nationaux
de freiner l'épidémie est ce que vous
pensez qu'il a raison lille et veyran ou
faudrait-il davantage de débats selon
vous aurez davantage de débats
franchement au parlement au tant à
l'assemblée qu'au sénat
depuis le début on se sont mises à
l'écart on est informé a posteriori et
encore pas dans la totalité des
informations nécessaires
vous serez également s'appuyer davantage
sur les collectivités vous avec le sénat
et l'assemblée des collectivités des
maires des présidents
d'intercommunalités sont prêts
aujourd'hui à donner les moyens
logistiques pour organiser des sessions
de vaccination mais le le premier
maillon de la chaîne c'est
l'approvisionnement en vaccins en doses
donc c'est là qu'il faut mettre le
paquet aujourd'hui on va parler du
gouvernement qui s'est réuni hier en
séminaire pour faire le bilan
on va voir comment il peut relancer les
réformes c'était l'objet de ce séminaire
voyez ce qu'a dit gabriela talent hier
il a été interrogé justement sur la
remise sur la table de la réforme des
retraites
ça reste une priorité pour nous de ce
quinquennat à l'agenda de ce quinquennat
parce que nous l'avons portée dans le
cadre de la campagne électorale parce
que ce sont des réformes qui sont
nécessaires un stage est une priorité
maintenant on le sait est ce que dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire il faut
maintenir ces réformes selon vous mais
monsieur macron arrive dans le dernier
tiers de son mandat il et il avait une
feuille de route pour commencer son
mandat
on sait par qui il a été élu on sait
qu'ils qu'il représente ce qu'ils
portent
même s'ils s'en défendent ce maquereau
est un nouvel avatar du libéralisme est
parmi les grandes réformes du
libéralisme idéal la fin du modèle
social français dont font partie le
système des retraites il ya également la
question de l'allocation d'assurance
chômage voilà il reste un tiers de
mandat monsieur macron veut accomplir sa
feuille de route pour commander rêve
remplir sa mission telle qu elle a été
assignée par les marchés financiers le
monde de la finance ou parler clair
le libéralisme voilà coûte que coûte
même dans cette situation de pandémie
très grave pour notre pays on vient d'en
parler ont remis en avant cette réforme
des retraites qui avait été rejetée
majoritairement de l'opinion lorsqu'elle
était en débat dans le pays à
l'assemblée franchement c'est pas
l'urgence l'urgence est de répondre à
cette épidémie
il avait parlé de guerre à bien il faut
mobilisation générale autour de cette
pandémie pour sortir de cette crise qui
épuise tout le monde et il ya besoin
d'espoir merci beaucoup à éric bocquet
on va finir sur ce mot espoir merci je
rappelle que vous êtes sénateur
communiste du nord